well i have not yet played mr dangerous
right today
so this is a must obviously
um let's promote something let's promote
knight c6
d4 d5
i think this um this used to be called
anime soviet opening back in the days
not neem sawyer's defense but i'm so
much opening
so name savage opening is much worse
than the neem switch defense
but okay
one could not come up with two brilliant
openings right
so guess we can so long can go e5
that's what that's what you normally do
in these lines
so it takes d4 what's the point
just it takes d4 maybe
he does not need a big point yet
yeah okay knight f6
yeah so now we need to make a decision
so it's either we go bishop before
and then take on c3 or we go queen h5 i
kind of like queen h5
so we'll wait for him to to um
castle short and then try to check mate
one more nice thing about this setup
with the queen on h5 is that h3 never
creates a threat
with the king only one and once white
castles
you can consider some bishop takes h3
nonsenses
he plays queen b3
which i do not quite get he probably
wants to castle long
let's play bishop e6
with the tempo notes that we need to
provide canada castling long
but in general once he plays it
the bishop on g4 will be under attack so
there is nothing wrong with playing
just playing bishop e6 straight away
now i played rook 8 and this is probably
not a brilliant move
yeah exactly i mean i like 100 10 things
but you know what there is also a good
news
the good news is that we are given a
chance to sacrifice a queen
in a funny way and that we all
we also don't have a choice really so
we'll just have to pray
so now bishop plays h5 it will be made
by 93 check i mean he has to play it
obviously
and yeah of course white is winning
there
but i feel like with some little
creativity will be
we will be able to sort of make him a
little nervous
also i played this guy so so many times
and i feel like he deserves to win one
game for sure
so i will be even happy in a way
he goes to d2 i think it was better to
go to e2 because now
he allows nancy for checking some of the
lines
white is still better of course
and so now let's um
let's think of this a little so we can
just capture the knight
as the b spanish five we can also play
like knight c4 check
there are also some random moves like
bishop before
trying to confuse him but
okay we'll probably end up taking the
bishop anyway so let's not waste time
but this is not kind of dead lost i mean
this is just lost
but black has some ideas it's not uh
[Music]
i mean you can really mess it up with
white
so i guess rook b8 is a good move
preventing queen b5 check
it goes back to f3 we probably include
knight c4
and he plays king g3 like asking for
something him
so knight f6 or rg6
g6 crease creates a threat of
of bishop f5
so let's play g6
so now b super 5 he can take on c4
and it works
uh there is no there is no bishop f5
immediately
there is no knight f4 check followed by
followed by bishop f5 okay let's play
knight b to check then
and now maybe knight f4 or something but
he's trying to
he's trying to run to f1 and g1 so let's
stop that first
yeah that's what we have to do okay now
we go f5
g4 we can even play four here
[Music]
yeah and he lost some time okay i'm
sorry i think the final position was
still
winning for white also it was kind of
amazing